This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's an image that stuck with me from the early pandemic that I'll never forget. It's the image of dozens of cargo ships stacked high with hundreds of thousands of containers anchored off the coast of Southern California. They were all just sitting there. I remember passing them in my car and the containers were stacked almost as high as the bridge I was driving over. And then of course there were the grocery store shelves, empty of flour and olive oil.
这里是“99%无形”。我是罗曼·马斯。在大流行初期，有一个画面一直留在我脑海里，让我永生难忘。那是南加州海岸外停泊着的一幕：数十艘货轮高高堆满了数十万个集装箱。它们就那样停在那里。我记得开车路过时，那些集装箱堆得几乎和我正开着的桥梁一样高。当然，还有杂货店的货架，面粉和橄榄油被抢购一空。
In the east, I remember I really wanted baker's yeast for the first time in my life, but no dice. There were also big delays for online orders on everything from furniture, bicycles, car parts to PPE and medical supplies. Before the pandemic, you rarely heard people use the phrase global supply chain, the incredibly complex network of corporations and factories and transportation companies that we depend on to make and move goods around the world. We just ordered our stuff that was often made on the other side of the planet, and it came
在东海岸，我记得我这辈子头一次那么渴望买到面包酵母，但根本买不到。而且无论是家具、自行车、汽车零件，还是个人防护装备（PPE）和医疗物资，网购订单都面临着巨大的延误。在大流行之前，你很少听到人们使用“全球供应链”这个词——这个极其复杂的企业、工厂和运输网络，正是我们赖以生产和在全球范围内运送商品的依靠。我们只需要下单购买那些通常产自地球另一端的商品，它们就会
right to our front doors, sometimes within hours. The system seemed to be just humming along smoothly in the background. But Peter Goodman, who covers economics for the New York Times, says that for decades there had been signs that the global supply chain was actually on the brink of a meltdown. There's a guy at Oxford named Ian Golden who predicted that a pandemic would hit the global supply chain, cause financial shocks, bring the global economy to its knees. Peter says most of the warnings were ignored by corporate leaders. And then COVID hit.
直接送到我们的家门口，有时甚至只需几个小时。这个系统似乎在背景中顺畅地平稳运行着。但《纽约时报》经济记者彼得·古德曼表示，几十年来一直有迹象表明，全球供应链实际上已经到了崩溃的边缘。牛津大学有一位名叫伊恩·戈尔德的学者，他曾预测一场大流行将冲击全球供应链，引发金融震荡，并让全球经济陷入瘫痪。彼得说，大多数警告都被企业领导者忽视了。接着，新冠疫情爆发了。
The pandemic was more of a reveal than a source of distress. It was the moment where it was just inescapable that we are dependent upon these jury-rigged supply chains with inadequate supervision without enough regulation such that there are now some gaping vulnerabilities. For many of us, the pandemic was the first time we saw these gaping vulnerabilities in our global supply chain system. Peter's been reporting on how long-standing problems like corporate greed,
这场大流行与其说是一个痛苦的来源，不如说是一次揭露。它是一个让人无法回避的时刻：我们依赖于这些临时拼凑、监管不足、缺乏足够规制的供应链，以至于现在出现了巨大的漏洞。对我们许多人来说，大流行是第一次让我们看到全球供应链系统中存在这些巨大漏洞。彼得一直在报道诸如企业贪婪、
overseas manufacturing, and our appetite for cheap stuff are what made this system buckle in 2021. In his new book called How the World Ran Out of Everything Inside the Global Supply Chain, Peter's written about his findings, including one invention that really shaped the supply chain system we know and don't exactly love today. So the key innovation that allows companies to draw on suppliers around the globe is the advent of something we now take for granted, the shipping container. You know, before that, loading goods was the primary impediment to moving them around the globe. It was extremely dangerous work.
海外制造以及我们对廉价商品的渴望等长期存在的问题，是如何在2021年导致这个系统崩塌的。在他的新书《世界是如何耗尽一切的：全球供应链内幕》（How the World Ran Out of Everything Inside the Global Supply Chain）中，彼得写下了他的调查发现，其中包括一项真正塑造了我们今天所熟知且谈不上多热爱的供应链系统的发明。因此，使企业能够利用全球供应商的关键创新，是我们现在视为理所当然的事物的出现——集装箱。你知道，在此之前，装载货物是将其在全球范围内运送的主要障碍。这是一项极其危险的工作。
It was extremely expensive. You had these dock workers who would spend days and days just staring at piles of stuff. You know, how am I going to get this side of beef into the available space on this cargo ship alongside a drum full of chemicals and a bunch of shoes and bales of hay. It's like a three-dimensional jigsaw puzzle. People would be crushed by falling crate. Stuff would shift around and be damaged. Stuff would get stolen because it just wasn't a standardized process.
它极其昂贵。以前，码头工人们要花上整天整天的时间，盯着一堆堆的货物发愁。你知道的，我怎么把这块牛肉塞进这艘货轮上仅有的空间里，旁边还塞着一桶化学品、一堆鞋子和几捆干草。这就像是一个三维拼图。人们会被掉落的板条箱压死。货物会移位并损坏。货物会被偷，因为这根本不是一个标准化流程。
Then in the early 1950s, along comes a guy named Malcolm McLean. And he figures out by eventually standardizing steel boxes that you can load at the factory with goods and then use cranes to lift them onto the backs of trucks, onto trains, and onto ships. He can make it much easier to move cargo around. So what Malcolm McLean's invention allows is this seamless movement of goods from factories and now the container ship becomes an extension of the factory itself.
然后到了20世纪50年代初，一个名叫马尔科姆·麦克莱恩的人出现了。他通过最终实现钢制箱子的标准化，想出了一个办法：你可以在工厂里把货物装进箱子里，然后用起重机把它们吊到卡车后车厢、火车和船上。他能让货物的运输变得容易得多。因此，马尔科姆·麦克莱恩的发明实现了货物从工厂的无缝流动，现在集装箱船成了工厂本身的延伸。
And there's a couple of knock-on effects of this. There used to be people standing on the dock, working the dock, figuring out how to load everything efficiently. This was all done by a group of people called dock workers or longshoremen. Could you talk about that? What impact did the rise of shipping container have on those workers? Sure. So the shipping industry from inception has been looking to squeeze dock workers out of
这产生了一些连锁反应。过去，码头上总有人站着，进行码头作业，琢磨着如何高效地装载所有东西。这些都是由一群被称为码头工人或长岸工的人完成的。你能谈谈这个吗？集装箱的兴起对这些工人产生了什么影响？当然。从一开始，航运业就一直在设法将码头工人排挤出
the equation because dock workers are a natural source of labor mobilization. They hold a gun to the head of the global economy. If we don't satisfy them and pay them enough that they're willing to go do this dangerous, physically demanding work, then they can withhold their labor and ships don't move and trade doesn't happen.
这个格局，因为码头工人是劳动力动员的天然源泉。他们扼住了全球经济的咽喉。如果我们不能满足他们的要求，付给他们的薪酬不足以让他们愿意从事这种危险、体力消耗巨大的工作，那么他们就可以扣留劳动力，船舶就不会移动，贸易也就无法进行。
So, as a result, they have kind of built in pricing power and have tended to get very good deals. And so, a lot of the technology that's arisen, and today it's robotics and automated shipping terminals in the beginning was the shipping container is about diminishing the dependence on those human beings and squeezing them out of the cost equation and have there be less friction in the system. Yeah, yeah. So I want to ask about another innovation that you
因此，他们某种程度上具有内置的定价权，往往能谈成非常好的待遇。所以，涌现出的许多技术——如今是机器人技术和自动化航运码头，最初是集装箱——其核心都是为了减少对这些人类的依赖，将他们从成本结构中挤压出去，并减少系统中的摩擦。是的，是的。所以我想问关于另一项你
write about that drives the global supply chain. And it's not an invention like the shipping container. It's a concept created at the end of World War II called Just-In-Time and it was thought up as a way to help companies be more efficient. So could you sort of lay out where Just-In-Time came from and what it was meant to do? Just-In-Time is this sensible idea pioneered by Toyota that instead of operating the way Ford did where it's just you know All-on mass assembly make as many cars as possible Just shove them down the throats of the sales channels and let them figure out how to sell the product make as much product
所写的、驱动全球供应链的创新。它不像集装箱那样是一项发明，而是二战结束时创造的一个概念，叫做“及时生产”（Just-In-Time），人们构思它是为了帮助企业提高效率。那么，你能大致梳理一下“及时生产”源自何处，以及它的初衷是什么吗？“及时生产”是丰田开创的一个明智理念，即与其像福特那样运营——你知道的，就是大规模全盘组装，尽可能多地生产汽车，硬生生地把产品塞给销售渠道，让他们自己想办法把产品卖出去，生产尽可能多
It's possible. Well Toyota post-second world war is dealing with the devastation of the war. They got limited capital They have limited devastation of the war, they got limited capital, they have limited developable land in Japan because Japan tends to be very mountainous, and they say, that's not going to work for us. We need to operate more the way a supermarket manages milk. In fact, Toyota executives went to the United States and not only visited Ford factories, they visited supermarkets and they said, yeah, think like milk. The grocer needs enough milk that no customer leaves unhappy that they can't buy milk, but you don't want so much milk that some of it goes bad and you're spilling it.
的产品——丰田在二战后面临着战争带来的满目疮痍。他们资本有限，战争造成的破坏让他们资金有限，而且由于日本多山，可开发土地有限，他们说，这对我们行不通。我们需要更像超市管理牛奶那样来运作。事实上，丰田高管不仅访问了美国的福特工厂，还参观了超市，他们说，没错，要像牛奶一样思考。杂货商需要备足牛奶，让没有顾客会因为买不到牛奶而扫兴离开，但你又不能备货太多以至于有些牛奶变质浪费。
We need it to be delivered just in time. So Toyota takes this approach to making cars, and they have their suppliers clustered close at hand, and they say, just bring us the parts and components that we need in real time. Right, and this approach makes Toyota wildly successful, one of the most successful car companies on the planet. And then Toyota starts openly sharing its method with other automakers and then other companies
我们需要它“及时”送达。于是，丰田将这种方法应用于汽车制造，并将供应商紧密地聚集在周围，他们说，只需实时将我们需要的零件和组件送来即可。没错，这种方法让丰田获得了巨大的成功，成为地球上最成功的汽车公司之一。接着，丰田开始大方地与其他汽车制造商分享其方法，然后是其他
that don't make cars. They also study and use this just-in-time system. Could you talk about this moment when just-in-time sort of reaches beyond Toyota? Sure. So, you know, you go back to the 1980s when there's a lot of fear-mongering in the United States about the rise of Japanese industry. But there's also a lot of admiration. And Toyota's at the center of it. And suddenly every business conference you go to, or you look at the cover of glossy
不制造汽车的公司。他们也研究并采用了这种“及时生产”系统。你能谈谈“及时生产”超越丰田的那段历史吗？当然。你可以回想一下20世纪80年代，当时美国对日本工业的崛起充满了各种贩卖焦虑的言论。但也伴随着极大的钦佩。而丰田正是这一切的中心。突然之间，你参加的每一个商业会议，或者你看到的那些光鲜亮丽的
magazines like Fortune or Forbes, there are these celebrations of the Toyota production system or lean manufacturing it becomes known as. And everyone in the business consulting world, and especially McKinsey, is pushing the idea that lean is synonymous with efficiency, with the right kind of capitalism, and lean is good. Okay, so then in the 1980s, just in time makes this leap
杂志封面，比如《财富》或《福布斯》，都在歌颂丰田生产方式，或者后来被称为的精益制造（lean manufacturing）。商业咨询界的所有人，尤其是麦肯锡，都在大力兜售这样一种理念：精益就等同于效率，等同于正确形式的资本主义，精益就是好的。好吧，于是在20世纪80年代，“及时生产”实现了这一跨越，
as a kind of dominant managerial philosophy out in the larger business world where it becomes almost a pathology. There's a version of having anything in house other than what is making money right now. And that idea becomes supercharged. Could you talk a little bit more about how the consulting class and corporate executives push this to its limit. So by the dawning of what we can call financialization, which is the paramountcy of shareholder interests
作为一种占主导地位的管理哲学进入了更广阔的商业世界，在那里它几乎演变成了一种病态。除了现在就能赚钱的东西之外，内部保留任何东西的做法都被视为什么都不是。这种理念被大大强化了。你能多谈谈咨询阶层和企业高管是如何将这一点推向极致的吗？随着我们可以称之为金融化（即股东利益高于一切的至高无上性）的曙光初现，
above all, combined with the rise of business consulting outfits like McKinsey, I spent a lot of time in the book talking about McKinsey's role, this sensible idea of just in time because it's very crude imperative to just kill inventory. Inventory's bad. You don't want parts in warehouses.
再加上麦肯锡等商业咨询机构的崛起——我在书中花了很多时间讨论麦肯锡的角色——这种“及时生产”的明智理念，由于其极为粗暴的指令，即“消灭库存”。库存是坏东西。你不需要仓库里有零件。
You don't want extra product. And let's face it, the business consultants, their boss is the shareholder. And so everything is about making the share price go up. And in this vein, McKinsey pushes this idea that the template for corporate success is you fire lots of people, you turn full-time workers into part-time workers so that you can employ them when you need them and you're not stuck paying them and dealing with their hassles like their
你不需要多余的产品。而且坦白说，商业咨询顾问的老板是股东。所以一切都是为了让股价上涨。顺着这个思路，麦肯锡极力推行这样一种理念：企业成功的模范就是解雇大量员工，把全职员工变成兼职员工，这样你就可以在需要时雇佣他们，而不必被他们拖累，不用去应付他们的
family problems and sick children and their commutes. You just pay for when they're actually needed. People are inventory in the McKinsey transformation. And at the same time, you empty out your warehouses, you go just in time, you look for cheaper suppliers around the globe, which increasingly means greater distance between the place you're selling your good and the place you're making your good. And everybody pretends that the oceans don't really exist anymore because container shipping is so cheap and it's so reliable. And so, you know, it's a nexus of interests.
家庭问题、生病的孩子以及上下班通勤。你只需要为他们实际被需要的时间付钱。在麦肯锡的改造中，人就是库存。与此同时，你清空仓库，实行“及时生产”，在全球范围内寻找更便宜的供应商，这越来越意味着你销售商品的地方和制造商品的地方之间距离更远。所有人都假装海洋已经不复存在，因为集装箱航运太便宜了，而且非常可靠。所以，你知道的，这是一个利益交汇点。
The business consultants have come up with a perfect way for the corporate executives to lower their costs and increase their profits and make their share prices go up. And that means relying on container ships and supply chains that are spanning oceans. And this relying on someone else is one of the other key parts of this global supply chain, namely, offshoring and the role of China. Can you talk about that ascendancy and how China fits into the global supply chain?
商业顾问为企业高管想出了一种完美的方法，来降低成本、增加利润并推高股价。而这意味着要依赖跨越大洋的集装箱船和供应链。而这种对外部的依赖，正是全球供应链的另一个关键部分，即离岸外包以及中国所扮演的角色。你能谈谈这种崛起的历程以及中国是如何融入全球供应链的吗？
Yeah, I mean, it's a confluence of events that play out right at the same time. I mean, basically, China comes out of the Cultural Revolution in the mid 1970s, this time of extraordinary upheaval for men, violence, people are poor, they're beleaguered, and Deng Xiaoping consolidates power in China. And Deng Xiaoping reacts to the ideological upheaval of the Cultural Revolution by essentially concluding that ideology doesn't matter. What matters is national development.
是的，我的意思是，这是一系列在同一时期交织发生的事件。基本上，中国在20世纪70年代中期走出了文化大革命，那是一个对人们来说充满非凡动荡、暴力、贫困和困境的时期，随后邓小平在我国巩固了权力。邓小平对文革的思想动荡做出的反应，基本上是得出结论：意识形态并不重要。重要的是国家发展。
And he institutes a bunch of market-embracing reforms that brings this industrial boom to China. And at the same time, the Chinese government manages to get China into the World Trade Organization, which will crack open export markets for Chinese goods, because China has become the ultimate place to make products cheaply and at scale. And this serves the interests of publicly traded corporations in the United States who spend a lot of money lobbying the Clinton administration. I mean, Clinton comes into office and not even a decade later, he's leading the charge to get China into the WTO because he's vacuuming up campaign contributions from American retailers
他推行了一系列拥抱市场的改革，给中国带来了这场工业繁荣。与此同时，中国政府成功加入了世界贸易组织，这将为中国商品打开出口市场，因为中国已经成为了以低成本、大规模制造产品的终极之地。这迎合了美国上市公司的利益，他们花了大笔金钱游说克林顿政府。我的意思是，克林顿上台甚至不到十年，他就带头推动中国加入世贸组织，因为他正在从美国零售商
and manufacturers who are eager to make use of Chinese labor to drop the costs of production. And China becomes like super specialized, become the factory of the world. I mean, you write that in 2021, Chinese companies are making something like 80% of the world's air conditioners, two thirds of our mobile phones. And this work gets spread across various regions in China
和制造商那里吸纳竞选捐款，这些零售商急于利用中国劳动力来降低生产成本。中国变得超级专业化，成为了世界工厂。我的意思是，你写道，在2021年，中国公司制造了世界上大约80%的空调、三分之二的手机。这项工作被分散到中国的各个地区，
so that different provinces have their own specialties. So how did that happen? Like how did China go from having all these different regional niches here and there to where the whole country is eventually dominating world markets? Yeah, so I was actually based in China from 2001 to 2006. And so I saw up close what unfolded
以至于不同的省份都有自己的特长。那么这是怎么发生的呢？中国是怎么从这里那里拥有各种区域细分利基市场，最终演变成整个国度主导世界市场的？是的，实际上我在2001年至2006年常驻中国。所以我近距离见证了
after China enters the WTO. And what happens is all this foreign investment pours in and individual towns become, you know, oh, that's the microwave town where suddenly 40% of all the microwave ovens are made in this parafactory in Guangdong province. Oh, over here in Zhejiang province, all the neckties are made here. Suddenly Italian necktie plants are going out of business as China takes 60, 70% of the world's share of making neckties.
中国加入世贸组织后发生的一切。发生的情况是，所有这些外国投资蜂拥而入，各个城镇纷纷变成——哦，那是微波炉之乡，突然之间，广东省某个村镇工厂生产了全球40%的微波炉。哦，这边在浙江省，所有的领带都在这里制造。随着中国占据了全球领带制造份额的60%、70%，意大利的领带厂突然开始倒闭。
And so it goes, blue jeans, t-shirts. It starts small and eventually turns into electronics. And of course, now we know computing elements. So eventually China emerges as the so-called factory floor to the world. I mean, if all the production is over there and you wanna make something in the 21st century and you wanna be remotely competitive with other people who are making stuff, you either go to China or you're out of business.
事情就这样发展下去，从牛仔裤、T恤衫开始。它从小处着手，最终转向了电子产品。当然，现在我们知道了，还有计算元件。因此，中国最终崛起为所谓的“世界工厂”。我的意思是，如果所有的生产都在那边，你想在21世纪制造点什么，并且想在与其他制造东西的人的竞争中保持哪怕一点竞争力，要么你去中国，要么你就得关门大吉。
["The Daily Show"] Coming up, as the global supply chain buckled during COVID, one US toy maker went on a nail-biting mission to get his products on shelves in time for Christmas. What that story teaches us about how the whole system broke and how to fixge as the Center of International Manufacturing Starting in the early 2000s, China began to emerge as the center of international manufacturing. But when COVID hit, China also became the epicenter of a global supply chain crisis. In his book, Peter Goodman traces the chaos that Meltdown created, particularly for a toy company called Glow. That's G-L-O. No W. Glow. One of the countless businesses
（《每日秀》）接下来：随着新冠大流行期间全球供应链的崩塌，一家美国玩具制造商踏上了一场让人捏一把汗的使命，试图赶在圣诞节前将产品摆上货架。这个故事告诉了我们整个系统是如何崩溃的以及如何进行修复……21世纪初，中国开始崛起为国际制造中心。但当疫情爆发时，中国也成为了全球供应链危机的风暴中心。彼得·古德曼在他的书中追溯了这场崩溃所带来的混乱，特别是对一家名为Glow的玩具公司而言。就是G-L-O。没有W。Glow。它是深陷供应链地狱的无数企业之一。
that was stuck in supply chain hell. At the start of the pandemic, Glow was a relatively young company created just six years earlier by an entrepreneur named Hagen Walker. Yeah, Hagen Walker's an interesting character. He's a guy who graduated from Mississippi State University in Starkville, Mississippi, graduates with this degree in engineering, has an internship at Tesla, turns down a full-time job because he wants to go back to his college town and start his own business.
大流行刚爆发时，Glow是一家相对年轻的公司，由一位名叫哈根·沃克（Hagen Walker）的企业家在仅仅六年前创立。是的，哈根·沃克是一个有趣的人物。他毕业于密西斯比州斯塔克维尔的密西西比州立大学，获得工程学学位，曾在特斯拉实习，但他拒绝了一份全职工作，因为他想回到自己的大学所在地创业。
Hagen started out making small novelty plastic cubes that lit up when you drop them in water. His first customers were bartenders who used the cubes to add a little flair to their cocktails. He developed that idea into light up bath toys. In 2019, that innovation landed him an incredible opportunity. This turns into a deal to make floating bath toys for Sesame Street, themed for Elmo and
哈根最初制作的是一些小巧的新奇塑料方块，丢进水里就会发光。他的第一批客户是调酒师，他们用这些方块为鸡尾酒增添一点情调。他把这个想法发展成了发光洗澡玩具。2019年，这一创新为他赢得了一个不可思议的机会。这变成了一笔生意，为《芝麻街》制作漂浮洗澡玩具，主题是艾摩（Elmo）和
Julia, a new character Sesame Street introduced around 2020, who has autism. This Sesame Street contract was the most important deal Hagen-Walker startup had ever had. The goal was to have the bath toys on shelves in time for the 2021 holiday shopping season. At first, Hagen planned to get all the parts he needed made domestically, but he quickly learned that it was going to be incredibly expensive, if not impossible, to manufacture his toys in the U.S. And finally somebody in Georgia says, you know, this is too complicated. You got to make this in China. When production has moved to China, you either go there or you have a hard time making stuff. And so he follows the path of
朱莉娅（Julia）——《芝麻街》在2020年前后引入的一个患有自闭症的新角色。这份《芝麻街》合同是哈根·沃克的初创公司有史以来接过的最重要的交易。目标是在2021年假日购物季之前将这些洗澡玩具摆上货架。起初，哈根计划在本土制造他需要的所有零件，但他很快了解到，在美国制造玩具将极其昂贵，甚至是不可能的。最后，佐治亚州的一个人对他说，你知道的，这太复杂了。你必须在中国制造。当生产转移到中国时，要么去那里，要么你制造东西就会变得举步维艰。于是他顺从了
least resistance. In late 2020, Hagen decided to get his toys made in China, where he learned that some parts of the process would be 12 times cheaper than in the US. But as the pandemic spread, Hagen soon found out how fragile the global supply chain really was. China is struggling to turn itself back on. There are still COVID lockdowns, the worst ones in Wuhan, which is where COVID first emerges in early 2020 or actually late 2019. And there are shortages of all sorts of components and China is not Unwilling to exercise state power and so he needs plastic to make these dolls He's told by his factory in in the city of Ningbo China You better make the biggest order you can in one shot because you're gonna have a hard time
阻力最小的路径。2020年底，哈根决定将玩具放在中国制造，在那里他了解到，生产过程的某些环节可以比美国便宜12倍。但随着大流行的蔓延，哈根很快发现全球供应链实际上是多么脆弱。中国正在艰难地恢复运转。仍然存在新冠封控措施，其中最严重的是武汉——大流行于2020年初（实际上是2019年底）首次爆发的地方。各种零部件都出现短缺，而中国并不吝于行使国家权力，所以他需要塑料来制作这些玩偶。
Finding plastic the government's having us prioritize use of plastic for things like medical devices. Kind of hard to argue with the logic of that. Like, you know, what do we need more? Ventilators or, you know, light up Elmo dolls. People are afraid of the pandemic. There are restrictions on movement. So this factory says, we're having a hard time employing enough people. We're not sure about the raw materials.
他被他在中国宁波市的工厂告知：你最好一次性下最大规模的订单，因为你以后很难找到塑料了。政府要求我们优先将塑料用于医疗设备等事情。这个逻辑实在让人难以反驳。就像，你知道的，我们更需要什么？是呼吸机，还是会发光的艾摩玩偶？人们对大流行感到恐惧。出行受到了限制。所以这家工厂说，我们很难雇用到足够的人手。我们对原材料也没有把握。
Place the biggest order you can possibly afford. So that's what Hagen does. Right, and then the toys get made. And then what happens to them? So when it's time to get the order shipped, that's when things get really alarming. That's when Hagen goes on a website called Freitos. Think of this as like Expedia for people
下你能负担得起的最大订单。于是哈根就这样做了。没错，然后玩具制造出来了。接下来它们怎么样了？所以，当到了安排订单出货的时候，事情才真正变得令人担忧。这时，哈根登录了一个名为Freightos的网站。你可以把它想象成是为需要
who need to book shipping containers. And he discovers that a journey that used to cost 20002,000 is now going to cost him $20,000 plus. Even as he's agreeing to these astronomical prices, he's saying to himself, I cannot disappoint Sesame Street. Elmo cannot be late for Christmas. I will pay whatever it costs. He's being told by shipping agents in Hong Kong, in the Chinese city of Shenzhen, in Queens, in Los Angeles. Hey, sorry, there's no room on the ship.
预定集装箱的人准备的Expedia（旅游预订网站）。他发现，一趟过去只需2000美元的行程，现在居然要花20,000美元以上。尽管他同意了这些天文数字般的價格，但他心里对自己说：“我不能让《芝麻街》失望。艾摩不能错过圣诞节。无论花多少钱我都愿意。”香港、中国深圳、皇后区、洛杉矶的货运代理都在对他说：“嘿，抱歉，船上没有舱位了。”
And it turns out, as I discovered in the book, this is happening throughout the importing world. I mean, even large companies like Columbia Sportswear that have contracts to move certain number of containers per month are being told, oh, sorry, no room on the ship. But actually, there is room on the same ship if you're willing to pay expedited handling fees, special pandemic surcharges, all sorts of made up names for things that amount to paying a lot more for the thing that you thought you had contracted. This really is as if we showed up as consumers at LAX thinking we're going to get on a plane
事实证明，正如我在书中发现的那样，这种情况在整个进口界都在发生。我的意思是，甚至像哥伦比亚运动服装公司（Columbia Sportswear）这样拥有每月运输一定数量集装箱合同的大公司，也被告知：“哦，抱歉，船上没有舱位了。”但实际上，如果你愿意支付加急处理费、特殊的疫情附加费以及各种巧立名目的费用——这些费用意味着为你原本以为已经签下合同的东西支付远超预期的价格——同一艘船上其实是有舱位的。这真的就像我们作为消费者来到洛杉矶国际机场（LAX），以为自己能登上飞往
for JFK. That's what it says on the ticket. We bought the ticket. And they say to us, no, no, we don't have space. But if you'll pay 10 times as much, well, we got space right now. And otherwise, you're going to keep waiting. And this is what's happening to Hagan and to importers in general. Yeah.
肯尼迪国际机场（JFK）的航班一样。机票上就是这么写的。我们买了票。而他们对我们说：“不，不，我们没有舱位了。但如果你肯出十倍的价钱，好吧，我们现在就有舱位。否则，你就继续等着吧。”这就是哈根和广大进口商们正在遭遇的事情。没错。
Okay. So you write that one of the big problems manufacturers were facing with the global supply chain was a gross miscalculation of how COVID would affect demand. Could you explain what everyone got wrong? One of the things that has happened is the people running global businesses have wildly flubbed the forecasting of what's supposed to happen in the pandemic.
好的。所以你写道，制造商们面临的全球供应链的重大问题之一，是对新冠疫情将如何影响需求做出了严重的误判。你能解释一下大家到底错在哪了吗？发生的事情之一是，运营全球业务的人们对大流行中本该发生的情况进行了极其离谱的预测。
Economists look at the fact that factories can't produce not just in China, but in Europe and eventually in North America, and people are getting thrown out of work, unemployment rates are going up, and they say, okay, we get it. This is going to be a nasty recession. There is spending power being taken out of the economy because people are losing their jobs, and as a result of that, there will be less demand for all sorts of things. Transportation companies say, well, if we're running a shipping carrier, we're not going to need as many ships, so we'll park some in warm waters in Greece and just wait till
经济学家们看到，不仅在中国，而且在欧洲乃至后来的北美，工厂都无法生产，人们失业，失业率上升，于是他们说：“好吧，我们懂了。这将是一场严重的经济衰退。”由于人们失去了工作，经济中的消费能力被抽走了，因此，对各种事物的需求将会减少。运输公司说：“好吧，如果我们运营一家货运公司，我们将不需要那么多船，所以我们可以把一些船停在希腊的温暖水域里，等着
the economy comes back. Computer chip manufacturers get reductions in orders for computer chips, and so their own suppliers get reductions, and so on. So when it goes, well, what actually happens as we now learn is that it's true, we're not going to offices anymore, so the local sandwich shop doesn't have any business, and those people are laid off, but we're now stuck at home, you know, cooking 27 meals a day for cooped up school children. And we now actually need more kitchen appliances.
经济复苏。”电脑芯片制造商的芯片订单减少了，因此他们自己的供应商的订单也减少了，以此类推。所以当情况发展下去时，正如我们现在所了解到的那样，实际发生的是：确实，我们不再去办公室了，所以当地的三明治店没有生意了，那些人被解雇了，但我们现在被困在家中，（你知道的）要为关在家里的学龄儿童一天做27顿饭。我们现在实际上需要更多的厨房电器。
We're not going to the office, but now the bedroom is the office. We need desk chairs. We need more computer monitors. We need iPads for the kids, trampolines for the backyard. We need all of this stuff. And a lot of that stuff is made in China specifically. So there's this surge of demand. This is what Hagen is leaning into.
我们不用去办公室了，但现在卧室就是办公室。我们需要办公椅。我们需要更多的电脑显示器。我们需要给孩子们的iPad，后院的蹦床。我们需要所有这些东西。而其中很多东西都是中国特制的。所以这就产生了一波需求激增。这就是哈根正在顺应的趋势。
At the same time, he's trying to make his cubes. Everybody's trying to make stuff. And then when stuff eventually gets made, the shipping industry gets overwhelmed because they've effectively mothballed some of their fleet. And then they discover that makes prices skyrocket. We can charge whatever we want and people are so desperate to get their products to home markets in time for Christmas. They'll pay whatever it takes. Oh, that's actually really good.
与此同时，他在努力制造他的方块。每个人都在努力制造东西。然后，当东西最终被制造出来时，航运业却被压垮了，因为他们实际上已经封存了部分船队。接着他们发现这导致价格飙升。我们可以收取任何想要的费用，而人们是如此迫切地想要将产品运回国内市场以赶上圣诞节。他们会付出任何代价。哦，这其实真的很好。
Yeah. And this is another place where Hagen gets snacked because once his toys are made and ready to go, he can't find a shipping container in China that he can use to bring them to his warehouse in Mississippi. And that's because these shipping companies, they're just making a killing moving factory goods from China to the west coast of the US and then sending the empty container back to China to refill as fast as possible to make the trip again. And so that's all they want to do. But Hagen was desperate to get his toys to the US.
是的。这也是哈根受挫的另一个地方，因为一旦他的玩具制造完毕并准备就绪，他在中国就找不到可以用来运往密西西比州仓库的集装箱。这是因为这些航运公司正靠着将工厂货物从中国运往美国西海岸赚得盆满钵满，然后又以最快速度把空集装箱送回中国重新装满，再次开启航程。所以这才是他们唯一想做的事。但哈根急切地想要把他的玩具运到美国。
So he just went crazy, working the phones, calling every agent he knew between New York and China. He fired off emails, he talked to factory owners, until finally he gets his bath toys in a container and onto a ship bound for Southern California, where there were even more supply chain issues. Yeah, yeah, for sure. Take the Twin Ports of Los Angeles and Long Beach. This is the gateway for roughly 40% of all imported goods reaching the United States by container.
于是他彻底疯狂了，不停地打电话，联系他从纽约到中国认识的每一个代理商。他疯狂发邮件，与工厂老板交谈，直到最后他把洗澡玩具装进集装箱，送上了一艘驶往南加州的船，而那里有着更多的供应链问题。是的，是的，确实如此。以洛杉矶港和长滩港这两个姐妹港为例。这是大约40%通过集装箱到达美国的进口商品的门户。
We got dock workers sick. We don't have as many working people. We've got a shortage of truck drivers because truck drivers are sick. And also, people are stuck in these long queues. The ships themselves, 50, 60, 70 ships floating, waiting for their chance to pull up at the docks because there's so much volume,
我们的码头工人病倒了。我们没有那么多劳动力。由于卡车司机生病，我们面临卡车司机短缺。而且，人们被困在长长的队伍中。船舶本身——50艘、60艘、70艘船漂浮着，等待着靠岸的机会，因为货量太大了，
fewer people to move this stuff at the other end. So the whole system just kind of buckles at once. And so in mid-October, we're talking just like barely over a month before the holiday shopping season starts the ships with Higgins toys Approach the port on Long Beach, right? And the first thing that happens is this ship gets stuck in a queue for several weeks where it's just floating around off the coast of Southern California with I got an estimate roughly a with, I got an estimate, roughly a billion dollars worth of stuff just floating there. We're talking like enough Heineken to satisfy the city of San Francisco for a year, enough
而终端能够搬运这些东西的人却更少了。所以整个系统一下子就崩溃了。于是在10月中旬——我们说的是离假日购物季开始仅有一个多月的时候——载着哈根玩具的船只靠近了长滩港，对吧？而发生的第一件事是，这艘船在一支队伍中被困了好几个星期，它只是在南加州海岸附近漂浮着，我估计大约有价值……大约价值十亿美元的货物就那样漂在那儿。
cornhole game equipment to satisfy the whole country for months, and this stuff is just floating in the ships surrounding Hagen Walker's vessel, which pulls up at the docks and a shipping agent he talks to in Queens, New York says, give up on rail. Rail is a fiasco. Let me see if I can get you a long haul truck. Now long haul trucking is besieged by delays. There's supposedly truck driver shortages, which is really the industry's way of describing the fact that they've downgraded this job to such a hellish state that they can't find enough
我们谈论的是：足以满足旧金山市一整年消耗量的喜力啤酒，足以满足全美数月消耗量的玉米洞游戏（Cornhole）设备，而这些东西就漂浮在哈根·沃克船只周围的货轮中。当他的船终于靠岸时，他在纽约皇后区交谈过的一位货运代理说：“放弃铁路吧。铁路是一场彻底的灾难。我看看能不能给你搞到一辆长途卡车。”现在长途卡车运输正被各种延误所困扰。据说存在卡车司机短缺，这实际上是行业的一种说法，用来掩盖他们已经将这份工作降级到了如此像地狱一般的状态，以至于他们找不到足够的人来
people to do this job. The minute unemployment goes down, people go do something else. Well, Hagen-Walker gets lucky. They find a truck driver, and the truck driver brings his container full of these Elmo dolls from Southern California to his warehouse in Mississippi in time for Christmas. It ends happily for Hagen-Wagen Walker, but not for everybody else. So despite all these obstacles, by the skin of his teeth, this works out for Hagen Walker.
干这活。一旦失业率下降，人们就会去做别的事。不过，哈根·沃克还算幸运。他们找到了一名卡车司机，这位卡车司机及时在圣诞节前将装满艾摩玩偶的集装箱从南加州运到了他位于密西西比州的仓库。对哈根·沃克来说，结局是圆满的，但对其他人并非如此。因此，尽管遇到了所有这些障碍，哈根·沃克还是千钧一发地成功了。
But in your book, he and others have discovered that maybe it's time to stop relying so heavily on China as the place where everything gets made. And they look at other countries around Asia and beyond in order to give themselves some more resiliency. But leaving China is much easier said than done. So what are the obstacles with this? So, you know, if you're a giant company like Walmart,
但在你的书中，他和其他人发现，也许是时候停止如此严重地依赖中国作为万物制造地了。他们开始把目光投向亚洲及其他地区的其他国家，以便为自己提供更多的韧性。但离开中国说起来容易做起来难。那么这其中的障碍是什么呢？所以，你知道的，如果你像沃尔玛那样是一家巨型公司，
then sure, okay, we'll move a little bit of production to India or Mexico or wherever. If you're a small business like Hagen Walker, you know, he actually comes out of the pandemic experience wanting to move some of his production out of China. He's concerned about the trade war. He's concerned about being vulnerable to increased shipping costs.
那当然，好吧，我们会把一小部分生产转移到印度、墨西哥或其他地方。如果你像哈根·沃克那样是一家小企业，你知道的，他经历了大流行之后，确实产生了将部分生产迁出中国的想法。他担心贸易战。他担心自己变得容易受到不断上涨的运费的影响。
So he takes a trip to Vietnam. He explores moving production there. He thinks about Cambodia. And in the end, he stays in China. And he shows me an app that he uses to order raw materials, it's part of Alibaba, it's like the Amazon of China. And he says, look, if I need some electronic component, I can put out a request for proposal in 15 minutes, I can have a dozen bids, I've got reviews of the factories that reply, I
于是他去越南进行了实地考察。他探讨了将生产转移到那里的可能性。他考虑了柬埔寨。但最终，他还是留在了中国。他向我展示了他用来订购原材料的一个应用程序，那是阿里巴巴的一部分，就像中国的亚马逊一样。他说：“你看，如果我需要某种电子元件，我可以在15分钟内发出求购意向书，能收到一打报价，能看到回复我的工厂的评价，我
can chat with people there pretty much 24-7, English is no problem at all. He said, if I tried to build that in Vietnam, it would take me years just to find a handful of suppliers, whereas China is set up to do this business. So in the end, he's decided that even though the risks are now evident, the rewards are too great and it's risky to actually move the business somewhere else. It will be very difficult for global manufacturing to break up with China. You have this story where the kicker to that is even if you do business with Vietnam, one of their components that they need to do
可以跟那里的供应商几乎全天候聊天，英语也完全不是问题。”他说：“如果我在越南试图建立那样的网络，光是找一小撮供应商就要花上好几年，而中国已经为这种业务做好了一切准备。”所以最终他决定，尽管风险现在显而易见，但回报实在是太大了，要把生意真正搬到别的地方去风险反而更高。全球制造业要与中国分道扬镳将是非常困难的。你讲过这样一个故事：其讽刺之处在于，即便你与越南做生意，他们用来完成
the thing that they're doing, they also outsource that to China. Vietnam is heavily dependent on the Chinese supply chain. That's reality. OK, but still, it seems like for US companies who want to build resiliency, one of the lessons is what they call nearshoring. Could you talk about how some companies are
他们正在做的事情所需的其中一个零部件，他们其实也是外包给中国的。越南严重依赖中国的供应链。这就是现实。好吧，不过尽管如此，对于想要增强韧性的美国公司来说，其中一个教训似乎就是他们所谓的“近岸外包”（nearshoring）。你能谈谈一些公司是如何
pushing to move manufacturing nearer to the US? Yeah, well, companies like Walmart. So take Walmart, for example. So 15 years ago, if you were a manufacturer of a retail product, you're hoping to get on the shelves of a Walmart superstore, and you fly into Bentonville, Arkansas, you have to go to them, by the way. It's like going to see the pope.
极力推动将制造业转移到离美国更近的地方吗？是的，好吧，像沃尔玛这样的公司。以沃尔玛为例。15年前，如果你是一家零售产品的制造商，你希望能进入沃尔玛大卖场的货架，你就得飞往阿肯色州的本顿维尔，顺便说一句，你必须去找他们。这就像去见教皇一样。
They don't come to you. You go in, you wait for your appointment with the buyer's representative at Walmart and they would ask you, where are you making this product? And 15 years ago, if you said anywhere other than China, you had a problem because the assumption was you couldn't possibly be getting the lowest possible price, could be making it most efficiently at scale. Well today, if you go to Bentonville and you have that same conversation with Walmart, where are you making the product?
他们不会来找你。你走进去，等待与沃尔玛买家代表会面的预约，他们会问你：“你在哪里制造这款产品？”15年前，如果你说出的地点不是中国，你就有麻烦了，因为当时的假设是你不可能以最低的价格获得产品，也不可能以最大的规模最高效地制造它。然而今天，如果你去本顿维尔与沃尔玛进行同样的对话——你在哪里制造产品？
And the answer is only China, you have a problem. They want a backup plan. And I've been writing stories about how Walmart's been moving production to Mexico, to Central America, to India. And this is all a reflection of the reality that they've discovered that you actually are leaving money on the table
而回答只有中国的话，你就有麻烦了。他们想要一个备用计划。我一直在撰写关于沃尔玛如何将生产转移到墨西哥、中美洲、印度的报道。这一切都反映了一个现实：他们发现，如果你不能保证产品有货，
if you can't keep your products in stock. Okay, so besides nearshoring, what are some of the lessons learned to avoid another meltdown like the one we saw during COVID? Like, do you have a prescription for how things could be better? Yeah, well, I think first of all,
你实际上就是在拱手让出真金白银的利润。好的，那么除了近岸外包，为了避免像我们在疫情期间看到的又一次崩溃，我们还吸取了哪些教训？比如，你对如何让情况变得更好有什么药方吗？是的，好吧，我认为首先，
we gotta have serious antitrust enforcement. And we've seen some of that from the Biden administration, Well, I think first of all, we got to have serious antitrust enforcement. And we've seen some of that from the Biden administration, but there needs to be follow through. I mean, the fact that we have entrusted much of our productive capacity to these industries, rail in particular, shipping another, where we have de facto monopoly power, able to dictate prices, and manipulating the supply of their services so that we're constantly in a state of agitation about our ability to move goods.
我们必须进行严肃的反垄断执法。我们在拜登政府身上看到了一些这方面的迹象，好吧，我认为首先，我们必须进行严肃的反垄断执法。我们在拜登政府身上看到了一些这方面的迹象，但这需要有后续行动。我的意思是，事实上我们将很大一部分产能托付给了这些行业——特别是铁路业，还有航运业——在这些行业中，我们有着事实上的垄断力量，它们能够左右价格，并操纵其服务的供应，以至于我们对于货物运输能力的信心始终处于焦虑状态。
That's just simply got to be looked at by government antitrust enforcement authorities. And then to realize that it was absurd to treat a factory in southern Ohio as the functional equivalent of a factory in China. That's not to demonize the factory in China, and it's not to demonize globalization, but to recalibrate it so that it makes common sense. We need backup supplies. By the way, just in time works better if more of our productive capacity is closer to the consumer. And I think, you know, our own experience in the last few years when we've heard so
政府反垄断执法部门必须对此进行审查。然后还要意识到，把俄亥俄州南部的工厂当作中国工厂的功能对等物是荒谬的。这并不是要妖魔化中国的工厂，也不是要妖魔化全球化，而是要重新校准它，使其符合常识。我们需要备用物资。顺便说一句，如果我们的更多产能离消费者更近，及时生产（Just-In-Time）的运作效果会更好。而且我认为，我们在过去几年里自身的经历——当时我们听到了
much about these supposed labor shortages, well, most of the time when we dig into labor shortages, what we find are that workers have been getting a bad deal for years. They've lost the ability to balance their family lives and their own interests with their work In many instances people are working very very hard and are still at poverty they require government supports like food stamps just to keep themselves fed and people are fed up and when there's a shock and Unemployment drops and people have bargaining power, they're going to demand a better deal. I think that, I guess, the thing I would prescribe is the realization that we've optimized the supply chain for big box retailers and we've done that in the name of anything that drops
那么多关于所谓劳动力短缺的言论——好吧，大多数时候，当我们深入探究劳动力短缺时，我们发现的是工人们多年来一直受到不公对待。他们失去了平衡家庭生活和自身利益与工作的能力。在许多情况下，人们工作非常非常努力，却仍然处于贫困之中，他们需要诸如食品券之类的政府补贴才能解决温饱，人们已经受够了。当发生冲击、失业率下降且人们拥有议价能力时，他们就会要求更好的待遇。我想，我开出的药方是意识到：我们为了大型零售商优化了供应链，而我们这样做的名义是，任何能降低
prices is good for consumers and anything that's good for consumers is good for society. Well, find me the person who's only a consumer. We are consumers, we are workers. We are parents, we are children. And the whole thing will work in much more stable fashion, whether that's the capacity to make a ventilator in the middle of a pandemic or amuse ourselves with light up tubes, whatever it is, people have to get paid enough that they feel a real incentive to keep doing the thing that we would like them to do.
价格的东西对消费者都是好的，任何对消费者好的东西对社会就是好的。好吧，请帮我找出那个仅仅是消费者的人。我们是消费者，我们是工人。我们是父母，我们是孩子。整个系统将以更稳定的方式运作，无论是大流行期间制造呼吸机的能力，还是用发光管自娱自乐，无论是什么，人们必须得到足够的报酬，让他们感到有真正的动力去继续做我们希望他们做的事情。
And how do you get people to internalize the human cost of an efficient global supply chain? Like, your book is a very humanist book. Like, you can sense your outrage of the Union Pacific railroad worker worker who has to camp on the side of the road now or something like that. If part of making this resilient for all of our sake and making the world a better place is putting yourself in the mind or recognizing what has been happening to the working class,
那么，你如何让人们内化高效全球供应链背后的代价值呢？就像，你的书是一本非常有人文主义色彩的书。比如，你能感受到你对联合太平洋铁路公司工人的愤怒，那个工人现在不得不露营在路边或类似的地方。如果为了我们大家的利益让这个系统更具韧性，让世界变得更美好的一部分工作是设身处地去想，或者认识到工人阶级一直在发生的事情，
how do you do that? How do you build that into the values of your system? I think you have to find a way at a regulatory level to diminish the incentives to just do whatever it takes to make your share prices go up. And some of that's antitrust. And some of it is labor safety regulations, workplace safety regulations, food safety regulations. But one of the things that I think is most important for consumers to ask to the extent
你该怎么做？你如何将这一点融入你系统的价值观中？我认为你必须在监管层面找到一种方法，来削减那种不惜一切代价让股价上涨的激励机制。其中一部分是反垄断。一部分是劳动安全法规、职场安全法规、食品安全法规。但我想对消费者来说最重要的事情之一，就消费者会考虑这些事情的程度而言，
to which consumers are going to be thinking about these things is, where's my money going exactly? I mean, we like to think of ourselves as the swashbuckling capitalist society. We've got a lot of corporate welfare in our society, and a lot of it comes at the expense. I mean, the subsidy is often the safety or ability to spend time with your family or enjoy your life or go see a doctor when you need to. That's a subsidy that, as Barbara Ehrenreich once put it, and I quote her at the end of the book, the working poor, they're like the ultimate philanthropists.
那就是我的钱究竟流向了哪里？我的意思是，我们喜欢把自己看作是一个勇猛无畏的资本主义社会。我们社会中有很多企业福利，而其中很多都是以牺牲某些东西为代价的。我的意思是，这种补贴往往是以牺牲安全、陪伴家人的时间、享受生活或在需要时去看医生为代价的。正如芭芭拉·埃伦赖希曾经说过的那样，我在书的结尾也引用了她的原话，那是一种补贴，底层贫困劳动者就像是终极慈善家。
They are giving us their safety, their security, their time, so that the rest of us can get stuff that's cheap. Well, if there's one thing I hope my book will bring home for people, it's that there are a lot of costs to that kind of cheapness, and we all bear them. Because when you're a medical device manufacturer and you can't make a ventilator in the middle of a pandemic because you've gone so lean with your inventory or you haven't gotten enough people on hand in your factories, you don't get to say, well, at least our share price is high.
他们将自己的安全、保障和时间奉献给我们，好让其余的人能买到便宜的东西。好吧，如果说我希望我的书能带给人们什么触动的话，那就是这种便宜背后隐藏着巨大的代价，而我们所有人都得承担这些代价。因为当你是一家医疗器械制造商，在疫情爆发期间却无法制造呼吸机，仅仅是因为你的库存精简过度，或者你的工厂里没有足够的人手，你可不能说，好歹我们的股价还很高。
Nobody's buying that. Peter, the book is so nicely put together and entertaining and tells such a complete story. I really appreciate it. I loved reading it. So thank you so much for talking with us. Oh, thank you. Thank you so much.
没有人会买账。彼得，这本书结构精美、引人入胜，讲述了一个完整的故事。我真的非常感激。我很喜欢阅读它。所以非常感谢你与我们交谈。哦，谢谢你。非常感谢。
Peter Goodman's book is called How the World Ran Out of Everything Inside the Global Supply Chain. It is a fascinating read. So go check it out. We talked about a ton of stuff that didn't make it into this story. It's all in the book. It's fantastic. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Christopher Johnson, edited by Nina Potuck. Mixed by Martín González. Music by Swan Riau. Cathy Tu is our executive producer. Kurt Kolstad
彼得·古德曼的书名为《世界是如何用完所有东西的：全球供应链内幕》。这是一本引人入胜的书。快去看看吧。我们谈论了大量未能收录到这个故事中的内容。全都在书里。棒极了。《99%隐形》本周由克里斯托弗·约翰逊制作，尼娜·波图克编辑。马丁·冈萨雷斯混音。音乐由斯旺·里奥创作。凯西·图是我们的执行制作人。库尔特·科尔斯塔德
is the digital director. Delaney Hall is our senior editor. Taylor Cedric is our intern. The rest of the team includes Chris Berube, Jason De Leon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Gabriella Gladney, Vivienne Leigh, Lasha Madon, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, You can find us on all the usual social media sites as well as our new Discord server. There's almost 5,000 people talking about architecture, talking about the power broker, they're talking about flags. They're talking about podcast recommendations, which I actually put on there
是数字总监。德兰妮·霍尔是我们的高级编辑。泰勒·塞德里克是我们的实习生。团队其他成员包括克里斯·贝鲁比、杰森·德莱昂、埃met特·菲茨杰拉德、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、薇薇安·莉、拉沙·马顿、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、凯利·普莱姆、乔·罗森伯格以及我，你可以在所有常见的社交媒体网站以及我们的新Discord服务器上找到我们。那里有将近5,000人谈论建筑，谈论《权力掮客》，他们谈论旗帜。他们谈论播客推荐，这其实是我发到那里的，
because I was looking for new podcasts. It's where I'm hanging out most of the time. You can find a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
因为我在寻找新的播客。那是我大部分时间闲逛的地方。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到通往该频道的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。